el cerco legal cada vez se estrecha más
para las personas que quieren abortar en
algunos estados republicanos de eeuu
este jueves nuevas leyes empezaron a
implementarse en texas idaho tennessee
que se acercan todavía más a la
prohibición total de la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo los demócratas
condenaron a los conservadores
los legisladores que aprobaron estas
leyes extremas no confían en las mujeres
de sus estados para tomar decisiones
sobre sus cuerpos
por ejemplo en texas entró en vigor una
ley que prohíbe el aborto desde el mismo
momento de la concepción y fija penas de
hasta cadena perpetua para el personal
médico que lo practique la única
excepción es si la vida de la madre
corre peligro aunque es difícil saber
que cae en esa categoría
algo parecido sucede en idaho tennessee
donde la ley no recoge la interrupción
del embarazo ni en caso de incesto ni de
violación aunque un tribunal de idaho
bloqueó partes de la legislación que iba
a entrar en vigor como por ejemplo las
penas de cárcel para el personal médico
precisamente estos trabajadores
denuncian la confusión en las nuevas
leyes y la ambigüedad sobre que
representa un riesgo para la salud de la
gestante
médicos en estados restrictivos con el
aborto lo tendrán difícil porque cada
día se encontrarán con más situaciones
que no son necesariamente una emergencia
pero que necesitan tratamiento que
podrían llevar a complicaciones de salud
graves que podrían llevar a la muerte y
que no saben si pueden tratarlo o no sin
poner en riesgo su licencia cuidado
además de las nuevas restricciones en
texas tennessee y idaho el viernes se
implementará otro veto casi total en
dakota del norte y el sábado en oklahoma
eso significa que este fin de semana una
de cada tres mujeres en edad
reproductiva de eeuu habrá perdido su
acceso a un aborto legal